[Music]
travis is in virginia beach hi travis
how are you
i'm well sir how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
so um i was wondering i'm 20 years old
currently i'm baby step 3. i have about
40
000 across all my savings accounts and
i'm just wondering on
what would be a good time to move out
and whether i should buy a rent
um i'm currently working two grubs and
running
a business myself and just a lot going
on right now
trying to decide what i should do sure
what do you make
last year i netted about 45-50
right around there good for you what do
you do
so i sell clothing as my business and i
work in a restaurant
and i work in a screen printing place
as well how many hours a week are you
working
so i work double shifts when i do work
uh two times
a week and then i run my business my
business i'm very busy during the
i ship i sell clothing so i ship you
know internationally
nationally go around buying stuff and
selling it so
yeah it's a lot going on you don't even
know how many hours you work you're
busting it aren't you
yes sir i would agree and your question
is
should you move out you mean move out of
your parents house somebody else's house
what are we asking
yes sir my parents house yeah i was
asking what i should buy a rent
i have a have a good chunk in savings as
well
i'd rent for a little while yep right
you're 20. i agree there's a lot going
to happen in the next three years in
your life
a lot of change is coming in the next
three to five years of your life and
and and uh you know one thing it's okay
to buy if you want to buy but i would
rent for a little while
and if you buy in a year and uh then two
years later you'll meet you meet the
special girl you will discover you
bought the wrong house
yeah she'll tell you that hey that's
that's as much truth as you'll ever hear
travis i promise you right now
so and then you'll have to move again so
it's okay it's all right
if you want to buy but here's the thing
sometimes there's so much pressure on
our culture to
to not throw money away on rent to own
that we buy
at a time maybe we shouldn't renting is
okay for short periods of time where
there's patience
involved and what your first step out of
the nest can be is just something very
simple
and you just pay the rent if something
breaks you call the landlord they have
to fix it you're not in the repair
business you're not in the
yard cutting business you're not in any
of these things you just live there and
keep working and piling up money
and you know in a year or two if you
want to buy something you're going to
have a really big pile of money by then
aren't you yeah my biggest concern was
a lot i still closed so i store
everything
in my house and just uh having this
having the storage like leaving at home
it would be a drive just to ship stuff
out
and like renting i couldn't i couldn't
run an apartment i'll have to run a
house
so so i was just you live in a house now
don't you
yeah it's just and inflating everything
is just a big concern
oh i'm not worried about inflation for
two years
right you're just getting started in
your career i'm not even worried about
inflation when the guy hustles like you
hustle i worry a lot more about lazy
people than i do inflation
yeah oh that's very true yeah you're
going to be all right man you're going
to be just fine
go if you want to rent a little house go
rent your little house i don't care you
don't have to run apartment
yeah and you know have two have three
bedroom house and fill up the other two
bedrooms with your inventory
you're making bank on this what are you
doing buying used clothes and reselling
them
yes sir like ebay yeah ebay
different sites uh grilled is one yeah i
talked to a guy the other day that had
made thirty five thousand dollars last
year doing that
hold on a second buying oh you buy a
pair you know buy something for a
quarter at a garage sale
put on ebay for three dollars thrift
stores man
travis i got some clothes i need to sell
you buddy
no he buys his cheap son he sells
i get it dave i'm saying you're gonna
get four dollars out of this transaction
all day
right now i like this selling clothes
yeah no selling it's good you want him
to sell them for you you don't want him
to buy him from yeah he buys
he buys it for now i get it i get how
he's doing it he's heard him say thrift
stores he's going
to find it man you know thrift stores in
wealthy areas would you run for congress
and take over the world son
oh please no don't dave he'll go to
congress and it'll ruin him oh well
maybe he could ruin congress yeah i know
i'm cynical
i know me too the air up there in dc is
different
foul